the new year means the start of a new
labor law in California meant to protect
more than a million freelance and
so-called gig economy workers they do
jobs like pet sitting cleaning and
rideshare and delivery driving
supporters of the law known as 85 say it
pushes companies to recognize
contractors as employees giving them
access to benefits but uber and post
mates are suing the state hoping to stop
the new law Carter Evans has been
following the story and is in Los
Angeles Carter good morning so it's not
just the company some workers who are
supposed to be protected by this they're
actually opposing the new law right
that's right it's a fight that's
actually gaining momentum
uber and post mates have been joined by
other delivery companies now like lift
endure - and they're pouring 110 million
dollars in efforts to bring this issue
before California voters now in November
I'm working a job that I love I'm
working the hours that I want Jack
Kinney who drives for both uber and lyft
feels the new law threatens his freedom
and flexibility I'm certainly not making
less than minimum wage kiddie drives in
Los Angeles handling rides between times
spent with his six grandchildren and
caring for his wife battling cancer he
has concerns that a b5 will force
companies to give employees a set
schedule you put a schedule on me I'm
now no longer able to optimize my work
time and I'm gonna make less still many
in the gig economy insists they need the
minimum wage overtime sick leave and
other benefits the new law affords them
everybody should be able to have
benefits and be able to be part of the
system
uber and post mates are suing to block
the new law saying a b5 is an irrational
and unconstitutional statute designed to
target and stifle workers and companies
in the on-demand economy on Tuesday a
federal judge temporarily blocked the
law from impacting more than 70,000
independent truckers many who are owner
operators this law is bad because we're
gonna be forced to be employees when we
can grow as a small business
companies like rideshare provider lyft
have said the law will force drivers to
operate differently it would impact the
ability of drivers to work whenever and
wherever they want they would likely be
required to work on scheduled shifts
still some gig economy experts say the
law could have a significant impact on
companies adding potentially hundreds of
millions of dollars in labor costs this
is very much a scare tactic from the
platform's as a way to convince workers
that they should operate against what
would actually be something in their
best interests regulations not always
the answer but when it comes to the gig
economy some regulation is definitely
the answer now in a statement uber said
it joined the lawsuit to ensure that all
workers are equally protected under the
law and can freely choose the way they
want to work post Bates meanwhile says
it's not trying to seek an exemption
from the law but instead is calling for
labor talks with California lawmakers
Anthony Carter thank you
you